hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Orcs Must Die - I'm here with
Tom
yo that's Tom as you maybe are rolling
right along well he's doing something I
don't know what what are you doing just
upgrading okay I'm done
I changed my stuff we basically decided
that I'm gonna be the control guy he's
gonna be the kill guy so I got my wind
belt my crossbow with stun from Anna and
I got the tower traps because that's
what I do best and I got all the useful
stuff alright continue that last one
actually we went by pretty quick
compared to the other one yeah I was
pretty good not too bad except at the
beginning yeah well so long as we can
get like one spot you wait there going
this way I can't tell I think they're
going towards the rift now I think I
think we're actually in the or clan now
oh okay
rift just over there there's a there's a
gate and there's another gate over here
I presume yeah something like that
wait oh yeah there it is okay so I'll
just funnel them over here okay just so
long as we can have one area are they
gonna go up the stairs not if I block it
yeah I think they will if we do if we
try to funnel them though actually if we
funnel them up the stairs that might be
better no but all the traps are lining
up here see this we got these boiling
oil and allows if we're slowing it like
the series looks longer than
yeah I'm gonna assume that they're gonna
go with where this glowing light is
taking me okay yeah so I'm gonna start
setting up right here
you set up your stuff all around okay
actually maybe I could do two like that
yeah
although maybe it's best just a funnel
man gone no no maybe it's more
cost-effective yeah
okay now you do your thing okay - BAM
that should be good to start with I
could put more of it oh wait oh shoot I
forgot to check the noose thing side I
didn't change my layout
yeah this is fine we may at some point
have to blog up these stairs I'm not
sure all right I'm ready ready I'm ready
better not be
traps that's good yeah
get a headshot Samantha
I live for magic
it was sculpt grab that
why did I say why did I tell you to grab
what the happy doesn't does it count for
both of us I don't know I don't think
got a new door opening don't even matter
coming to the same place yep you want
some more
I'll never get through
I got this door
oh no they're going up the stairs damn
it I told you they were going you know
if you place barricades at the end of
the stairs down here would they like
loop all the way and then turn around
and come back
could be or they might just
no they won't that's better to actually
do whatever you
got it
work
I went through the stairs
all right that was easy new door don't
even matter
don't even I got lots of money so much
now fires those efforts
oh hi dad died I got hit by the
explosives you died come they trapped me
come on wasn't fair
life's not fair kids gone why didn't you
stop him I tried
ah they hit the rift to come up over the
stairs but it came up over the stairs
faster
well
let's go
I guess I shouldn't sling my back here
I think we could equally distribute the
blame it's all your fault I don't think
my fans would yeah I shouldn't have died
we want to rethink no the strategy is
fine it's just we got to block off this
area okay we got to block off here and
then make sure that they don't blow it
up okay so they did I mean I had
barricades right here
but I couldn't get to it in time that's
when I died I was running towards them
and then I hit got hit by them okay so
keep them down here yeah but it takes
three down here unfortunately yeah it
doesn't quite fit oh well we'll figure
it out
[Applause]
I'm staying I'm playing the back end
I'm gonna keep the tar traps here
somehow again it's fine
where are they oh they're up there I got
am I gonna watch
oh crap oh crap oh crap we're good
it's all good
it's not good not good it's not good oh
it's not good
I have like no man
Oh Tucker it's not good not good not
good
ah you failed
we met that kind of sock we've done you
have enough money for barricades here
wait no they're okay I blocked off the
top okay and I'll just have to make sure
that they don't destroy I can I can
always stand up here
Oh Cassie Severson I killed stuff ah
killed tappers come on what the [ __ ]
what happened I don't know I couldn't
hit him for some reason my crossbow went
stupid and it just completely missed I
wouldn't the mainland to the heads I'm
just aiming for them it'd be there
coming up here should turn around
yeah the Turner
if you watch down here I'll be okay you
walked up there I'll watch down here
what oh no nothing get off my ledge
I don't have enough for another one I
can't get down there today
what's it's not at our trap
ah man this is not going up what they're
actually they were just here attacking
your barricade
it was just a regular work swinging at
your bear game
oh six more levels to go they're
supposed to their stuff preparing so
that's good I'm uh I'm gonna put slow
track
zapper problem should be taken care of
good
oh that's a troll
I
they regenerate health
got down there
got it
ah [ __ ] barricades down nothing
what they got a barricade they're just
that they're just coming in there's
they're doing well they shouldn't unless
you're standing right next to one don't
know they were on the other side there's
that one turn around sometimes
exactly that's so weird that they didn't
do that in the first game
maybe they got smarter
we need one more very
I don't think we need all these slow
jobs over here no I think we could
probably spend that on something else
so which ones need to go could you this
one right here yeah and then I don't
think we need all the ones up there but
whatever you want to do
yeah this should get him
laughter I'll just leave this right here
others a coin over there I got mine
maybe if we did just block off the
stairs from the beginning it's fine okay
all right we're fine okay we're good
and never where I am
stammers oh boy got him definitely good
flanked us that's a new one degree
number two uh yeah
that's fine
where
up one got by
they really want to come up here no I
got it
and they meet enough on here no they
turned around okay go to those turned
around over there
it's what they're supposed to do
now it's got three over
lots of ogres but not a problem
come on die show me your head
turn around okay got the all the ones
down here oh I got the soldier will not
die I swear I'm I'm reading this guy in
the face old Andre did not die I've got
some wall traps that I could set up this
will be Florida
laughter yet
there
I climbed up here
just want to make sure none of those
blasters get there
sappers blasters whatever they're called
: why they called zappers sappers
sappers I don't know it's an old word
for
man there's a lot of these guys are they
getting through not as far as I can tell
yeah they seem it's it's
good
that's like stupid easy to come
damn stragglers
oh that's how they get occasionally the
the things on the ceiling
the area outside oh I was about to say
be pretty hard to get through otherwise
yep that's good to me
great good all right I've got money
oh you want to yeah I'm gonna do doubles
now won't matter which way they get
knocked
and sappers
sounded like it oh there they come
check upstairs
that is a lot of red dots
let's go get it go ahead go for I got it
done done yeah
it's like supremely effective
we got people
turning around
so I'm knock down
sit down
get down
another done
huh ready to go yep let's go
lots of money oh crap I got left I got
left
I'm just cutting them up
I got all the ones on the left oh wait
no more coming
got him
I mean I'm just assuming that everything
is gonna die down there
well they better
now I'm able to jump shot jump headshot
the soldier
now more I'm up here
like so much love them
Oh
like
there we go
good no problem
more traps what well I got our arrow
trap
give me a hand up here with you stuff on
the left on the left
last one let's write down here ah ha ha
you can even have the coin yeah what are
you gonna do with it yeah I got
[Applause]
but I got it
did you hear sappers know
this patrol is like the first mark
I think so
holy crap that's a lot of guys
oh no this one
fight
we lost something
oh they're attacking the bear kissing oh
my god why why are they
well they're not liars
have you hold it that's a lot of tones
fine you could put like I don't know a
lot of your fire traps on there
true
Oh
all gone
where where for what they said they're
attacking the barricade
I didn't hear anything
this is crazy yeah although I think we
may not be far but I mean it doesn't
matter
we for one
keep some film
jana rama
are all the maps designed to be played
with two people I don't know
this one could be done
but the other one click
yeah
actually this
yeah that's a weird dance to skulls your
guardian oh I love those guys so we cool
I should probably take those when I have
like excessive amounts of money yeah
this would be nice okay that's all the
time we got for this episode thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next video
bye bye bye